welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 20 and
we're gonna learn the most important
lessons from billionaires
enjoy
[Music]
one of the great secrets in life to
becoming successful
whether it's in a business whether it's
working with someone or for someone or
in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early 20s
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection
because if you're prepared for a lot of
rejection that comes you don't get
turned off you don't get disappointed
like well i'm not going to do this
anymore no one thinks it's a good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars
they slap them in your face you must be
just as enthusiastic
on door number 101 as door number one
and that's what the real secrets and
growing up as kids in downtown l.a
we all knew that we didn't have a lot we
noticed a lot of things going to turn
you down
at seven trying to sell a flower pot on
the street most people said no
but it's only 50 cents no no no sooner
a waitress a little restaurant said only
50 cents that's really great she bought
it from us
and we went built another one america
still has an opportunity
in 2000 i'm sorry 1980
inflation in the united states was 12
and a half percent
unemployment 10 and a half percent if
you could get a loan
if you could get a loan in 1980 and 81
your lowest interest rate
is 17 that's the primary okay
and you have to wait in line for
gasoline in our and our houses we're
still in iran
worst time to ever start any business
anywhere
when we started paul mitchell we went
for half a million dollars we had a
backer
never gave us a dime the day i left
everything i did
nope never gave us one dime the day we
were ready
the money was supposed to come in to
bank of america in universal city
my relationship wasn't going good i left
her the house the best car i took the
used car down the hill
a couple hundred dollars in my pocket
there's half a million sitting there
my partner flew it from hawaii paul
that's where he and his girlfriend lived
because he wanted some bucks he was on
his last dollars too and he's a little
older than i was
it never came in the money never came
and the guy said
sorry last minute change of mind he gave
us all the reasons as to why
so there we were zero we started paul
mitchell
with 350 each i lived in the back of my
car
and there's a good little film to watch
it's called good
fortune how in life you could start with
little to nothing you could be homeless
you could be fired from multi jobs which
i was by the way
and you can still succeed if you believe
in yourself
help people along the way no matter how
bad the circumstances are
i spent an unusual amount of time with
my
grandparents and especially with my
grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south texas
and i would spend my summers there from
age 4 to 16.
and they when i was four they were
taking me for the summer to kind of give
my parents a break
you know it's sort of because they were
so young um
and it was useful i was a handful i'm
sure
and uh and anyway he he
he he created the illusion for me when i
was four years old that i was helping
him
on the ranch which of course could not
have been true
but i believed it and um and then as by
the time i was 16 of course i was
actually helping on the ranch i
you know i could i can fix prolapsed
cattle i can
you know we did all of our own
veterinary work some of the cattle even
survived
um and we fixed windmills and
laid you know water pipelines and built
fences and barns and
fixed that fix the bulldozer that you
guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about that
lifestyle and about my grandfather is he
did everything
himself you know he didn't call a vet if
one of the animals was sick he figured
out
what to do himself and uh so what does
it mean no delegation being resourceful
i think is the you know that you can
always you can't if there's a problem
there's a solution and of course as you
as you
mature and and get into the business
world and anything you do on a team you
very quickly realize that
it's not about just your own
resourcefulness it's about
team resourcefulness and how does that
work and um
but that attitude of my grandfather's
influence was very but he was full of
wisdom
john mentioned the story about the words
my grandfather gave me at one point of
it's it's harder to be kind than clever
that story the slightly longer version
of that story because this was really
powerful
wisdom is that i made my grandmother
burst into tears
and the way i did it was we were driving
on a long
road trip and she was a chain smoker
and this was i was probably i don't know
10 years old so this was
around 1974 and
it was in a period of time where there
were heavy radio advertisements sort of
anti-smoking
radio advertisements trying to convince
people to stop smoking and
one of the advertisements had this
figure in it it said something like
um every puff of a cigarette takes
so many minutes off of your life i think
it was two minutes but i can't remember
every puff of a cigarette so i sat there
in the back seat on this
long car ride and calculated how many
years
she had taken off of her life and
in my 10 year old mind i had been
extremely clever to do this and so
when i was finished with my arithmetic i
um proudly announced to her how many
years she had
taken off of her life and i got a
reaction i did not
expect with her bursting into tears and
so my grandfather stopped the car and
he uh took me out of the car and i had
no idea what was about to happen because
he had never said a crossword to me and
i thought because he
might actually be angry with me but he
wasn't he took me out just because so
she we had some privacy from her
and he said this these incredible words
you're going to he said you're going to
figure out one day
that it's harder to be kind than clever
when you were in college
developing these skills you want to do
some things that were of benefit to
humanity
why why did you think that well because
not everyone does
yeah no i i guess it was um i it's sort
of a
existential crisis of like what does it
all mean and what's the meaning you know
what's the meaning of life and
uh is this 3 a.m over a beer or this was
well more seriously
it probably goes back to high school i
guess
i don't want to give a laboriously long
answer but uh
i was uh i yeah i had sort of a
dark childhood it wasn't good um
probably partially brought on by by
reading some of the philosophers like
do don't ever read schopenhauer
nietzsche if you're 14. it's
it's not good yeah or ein rand either
too yeah
yeah so um i was just trying to find
figure out what
you know what does it all mean and um
actually
uh when i read the hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy which i think is a great work
philosophy
um that sort of highlighted the point
that
uh very often the issue is understanding
what questions to ask
and if you can properly frame the
question then the answer is the easy
part
um so i thought uh things that uh expand
the scope and scale of the human
consciousness
um and allow us to better ask questions
and you know
and and and achieve greater
enlightenment those are good things
and so that's sort of what what can we
do that's gonna
most likely lead to that outcome what
other habits did you cultivate
in your 20s and your 30s that you now
see as being foundational to your
success as a business person
well i i knew a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i i i really read a lot and
and i aspired to learn everything that i
could about the subject
so intellectually i knew a lot i did not
know a lot about human behavior i mean
that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's
it's very important to understand people
and uh i say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
or you could be given 10 of the future
earnings
of one person that you know among
everybody you know
now are you going to pick the person
that's the smartest i'm going to pick
the person that can
dance the best or that can run the
fastest or anything like that that's the
right height no anything no no
you're gonna you're gonna pick the
person that has the right
habits that that is cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and
when you look at all of the qualities
that you admire in other people
which would cause you to pick that
person say to yourself which of those
qualities
can't i have myself because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper
who is the person that you admire the
most or like the best
why do i like them and just write down
and then say
which of these can i do myself and the
truth is you can do them
and then you also if you really want to
carry it to the next extreme you pick
the person you dislike the most
and why do you dislike that person you
know and you know
they always they're never fair about
things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities
and say if you just like that some other
person why in the world would you want
to have those yourself
so you should get rid of those and it's
it's a pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick
your best friend you know that you would
have the same qualities
you're 21 22 23 years old right
you don't have to figure it out right
now don't try
right you spend all this money sorry
um paying to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn and start
to be exposed to different ideas and now
it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
me five years ago you know it was like
get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for
ibm or general motors and get a pension
those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james
you know where you're always out there
and can go find a better situation for
yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
umeki
um
you know what how bad could it be i
would lose my motel six
towel you know it was just like what
have you got to lose and yeah i
understand there's pressure from student
loans and there's a lot of conversations
we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect
you can learn at that job and you guys
have the pedigree you have the brains
you have the initiative to go out and
try the next job
you know you know the good news is the
economy is good enough that it may not
be perfect but you can go job to job
don't look for the perfect answer just
look to get the experience look to
learn because all these different
exposures all the different things you
learn learning how to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juicy for for something that
you love
because once you find something you love
to do
that's when the magic happens because
when you're when you're
able to find something you love to do
then you can start work focusing on how
can i be
great at this and like greg found out he
was a great networker i like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself
then you can try to be great at it and
it's rare when people
quit things they're great at you know
and so
trying those things so that that's how i
advise people don't don't stress
just go out and try different things
speaking of learning from lessons
you've been around a lot of incredible
entrepreneurs and i know you did a
reality show with richard branson says
10 12 years ago you said yes
what was that like and what's been a big
lesson you've learned from him
and what was the show and what'd you
learn yeah the show was called the rebel
billionaire and it was
the apprentice version richard branson's
version of that
they were looking for 16 entrepreneurs
so i'm like hey i'm an entrepreneur i
want to do this and i really wanted to
meet richard
i sort of had set intentions out there
that i was gonna
manifest him becoming a friend in my
life so when i heard about the show i
was like oh this is interesting this
might be how this happens
so i applied for it and um
uh it was wild so it's how big how big
was spanx at the time was it really well
known was it like just kind of
it was pretty i mean it was four years
in it was doing great
yeah multiple seven figures and stuff
yeah my lawyers begged me not to do it
they're like what are you doing
you own this company you're gonna do a
reality show i was like i just want to
know richard i just feel like this is a
chance
so um so yeah and and all the business
challenges took place around the world
in different cities
and instead of if you didn't win the
business challenge going into a board
room to get fired you had to do
a crazy stunt like a world record
breaking stunt because richard is
obviously
like a huge adrenaline junkie guy so
um in addition to being an amazing
entrepreneur and the very first day of
filming i had to climb the side of a hot
air balloon at 9000 feet in the air on a
dangling rope ladder and have tea climb
to the top and have tea
on top of the balloon with richard
that's insane it's insane
what did you guys talk about on the top
oh my god i talked about like how do we
get down and that's what he said you
climb back down i was like
what i didn't think about that it was so
scary yeah oh my gosh
yeah so it took me 48 minutes to climb
to the top
it's at the height of a 17-story
building and the dangling rope ladder
was just like hanging out into the abyss
of nothingness wasn't anchored to
anything so i'm like
climbing it and um there's cameras that
was the first day of filming
so two months later i know i like
cameras up there
yes helicopters
i had to do all these crazy stunts the
next stunt i had to do is i had to jump
off the side of the victoria falls gorge
in africa on a with a bungee cord
attached to me and
my guy on my team was dangling on a wire
on a crane 10 feet out from the cliff
and each person had to come up and stand
there and you couldn't run and jump and
you had to stand still and jump
and if he caught you you were okay and
they'd put you back on the cliff
and if not you fell 385 feet on a bungee
cord
and so i am beyond terrified of heights
it's like one of my
i'm so afraid of heights i cry on
airplanes still during takeoff a lot of
times
and i was one of the only people to make
the jump richard didn't make the jump
all these other guys that were like
amazing athletes didn't make the jump
and i like to talk about this because i
always talk about aiming high
and the importance of aiming high in
life and that i think all of us we don't
aim high enough
and so watch where you're aiming and
that that's
saying you know if you shoot for the
moon if you miss you're at least with
the stars
and afterwards everyone's like sarah how
did you make that jump you're
literally like the only contestant and
look at you i said
well i was aimed at the pulley six feet
above
his head where were you aiming and i
aimed
i didn't even look at him i aimed six
feet above his head and i landed at his
waist and he caught me
and everybody else was aiming at his
face and landed at his feet
and missed amazing so it's like a really
just
poignant example of the importance of
aiming high
in all areas of life yeah yeah wow yeah
this is fascinating so what was the
biggest lesson you learned from
richard richard is um a really
uh he first of all is such a bias for
action it was fun to watch him have
he doesn't think things through to the
point you know
i mean it's unbelievable he has an idea
and before you're even done saying well
wait writing it on the napkin he's
doing it yeah he doesn't sleep much he
requires almost no sleep
um and he's always got a notebook with
him
writing ideas he delegates he's really
good at delegating he's very good at
empowering the people around him
and he didn't ask us to do any business
challenge any crazy challenge that he
didn't do himself
first he was doing it
yeah wow would you say he's the most
inspiring entrepreneur you know
or probably i mean he's just
yeah he's so he's so much fun he's a
multi-billionaire that still lives his
life like he has 20
in his pocket what does that mean what
do you mean it means he's
up for anything he there's no entourage
about him he's not afraid of anything
you know
sometimes i've seen some people become a
little bit more
reserved reserved or you know careful
and he still takes risks oh yeah it's
amazing have you been to his island many
times i have
yep necker island that's cool you did
grow up
poor is how you put it tough
situation yeah it was great how uh no
seriously it was the best thing that
ever happened to me well so i mean
seriously was it
it was incredible i mean in the time it
was horrible of course uh
lived above a laundromat in ottawa
ontario in a little
french ghetto called vanier but i went
to a really good
i went to a really good high school
listener collegiate every little
rich muckety-muck went there i didn't
and so i secretly hated all of them but
what it really was doing was lighting
this
unbelievable fire this like nuclear
reactor inside my stomach
where i'm just like i am just going to
win and uh
you know it wasn't really until waterloo
where it started to really unlock
again particularly in these work terms
where i was in the work environment i'm
like
i can crush i just knew that i could do
it uh
yeah so in hindsight it was the best
thing
now in part of it why was the best thing
is i've now taken enough time to be
introspective to self-actualize
and to deal with it but it came with
immense amount of baggage and you know
for a while
it was like i just needed to be rich
because i was so poor
and then you get there and then you're
like wow this is really going to amplify
either the best parts of my character
or the absolute worst parts of your
character and there was probably a year
where it was the worst parts of my
character but i
again it's like for me it's been it's
been a process a journey of
self-learning
and yeah it was a hugely instrumental
thing like i look at my children and i'm
like wow
like what boundary conditions could i
possibly even remotely give them
that will allow them to struggle in a
way that makes them want to achieve
great things
what do you do we've been talking about
that grit resilience all those things
apparent every parent wants it for their
child
and the better off you are i don't think
super rich is much different than
upper middle class uh because i totally
agree with you it just means they're
spoiled and you don't have to work for
me i totally agree
uh and i'm talking about my own kid
there spoiled doesn't have to work for
anything
i really worry about that yeah what do
you do um well i think that i think the
the thing that it comes down to is like
you know what is
what does grit and resilience come from
well one is like it has to come from
like a personalized struggle of
something that you care about
and so for me what i've been spending a
lot of time with now is what is the
context
that i need to set for my kids and
i think the context will probably be in
and around
whether it's like um like i think i can
do a lot of context setting in the
construct of healthcare
i think that in sort of like in an
educational world like i really do
believe like i'm going to give my kids
complete freedom to be able to
want to go and achieve anything they
wanted even in the absence of a degree i
just i think like
i want them to
[Music]
step off the bridge and fall and flat on
their face
and i don't have a toolkit of what the
tactics are
um but yeah it all comes back to this
idea of grit and resilience and oh by
the way
like the educational system has a huge
role to play too
like we have frankly like coddled and
like
diapered kids all the way up through
high school now where like you don't
really give
them and put them in a situation where
they can overachieve or underachieve
with any meaningful consequences
everything's managed to the middle
our sports infrastructure is all about
everybody gets to score a goal everybody
gets to get on the field
so it's not just a parental thing
because even if you try to do something
and
you know i don't know punch a kid in the
face and kick him out in the snow
it doesn't matter because everybody else
will be there with 19 blankets and a
warming hut
and you know and the police and the
police is like okay great i mean
so there's nothing you can do by
yourself so again it goes back to like
um ray dalio who i don't really
read a lot of but he's the founder and
ceo of bridgewater which is
the world's largest hedge fund um has
this book and i say i would tell you
skip basically all 285 pages but on page
286
he has a framework for talking about
economies and i think it applies to
kids which is economies are only ever in
one of four states
you're poor and you know you're poor
you're rich but you still behave like
you're poor
you're rich and you behave like you're
rich and then you're poor and you still
behave like you're rich right and it's a
cycle
and you can map all countries in the
world to this very simple kind of model
america is kind of rich behaving rich
india is
probably poor behaving poor china is
rich behaving poor
france is poor behaving rich you know
and you can you can figure it all out
and there's a version of that that i
think applies that i think applies to
like
to children which is like you have to
find a way um to create like these
struggles where
um you can create grit and resilience
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams there
is
there was a time where i used to spend a
lot of energy wanting things
wanting things of course it's easy for
me to say oh things don't define you
because i got a lot of things things
nice i like them but this is what i
learned
when you can surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power you get to live in the
space
that you purposefully have come to earth
to claim for yourself
so around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning uh
sunday morning
should have been in church but i
wouldn't
i was reading the new york times review
of the color purple and i thought whoa
this sounds like a really great book
i got out of bed in my pajamas put on my
galoshes
and went to the store to get the copy of
the color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple
i took the books to the office and i
said to everybody y'all got to read this
book oh my god you got to read this book
color purple i needed a book club i
didn't have one
so i pass out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear that somebody's
going to do a movie about the color
purple
but i don't know anybody in the movie
business by this time i was on am
chicago
i don't know anybody i start praying to
god god please help me find a way to get
into color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as as divine law would have it
quincy jones comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one
half of a day because somebody has filed
a suit against michael jackson
claiming that billie jean was their
lover and that's not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room he was coming
out of the shower and the television
in his hotel room is on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jarrett curl
on am chicago quincy jones
tells ruben cannon the casting agent i
think i found
sophia so i get a call for movement
cannon
who says i'm calling about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition
and i say i have not been praying for
moon song
[Music]
no
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well i think you should come and
and audition so i go to audition
you know movie people they make
everything all secret steven spielberg
didn't want anybody know he was doing
color purple so
on the outside of the script it says
moon song but i know
all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus
this is the color purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie
oh that i'm thinking prayer prayer works
[Music]
prayer works but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february march april
may comes i haven't heard anything so i
call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon i'm sorry sir i haven't
heard anything i expected to hear
something by now and reuben cannon
african-american man says to me
you don't call me
i call you and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick so i decide that this is
because
the fat has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose 25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i also was trying to make peace
with it i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says
real actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track at
the fat farm
it starts to rain y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god
to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life
i start praying running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i
i can't there's nobody on the track but
me and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me help me let it go
help me let it go help me let it go god
help me let it go and you ever did this
prayer where you say okay lord don't
come and let it go then you get up and
you go well i think i still got a little
bit of it
i did help me let it go but i am not
gonna be able to see the other actress
in my part i won't be able to see it
won't be able to see color purple
just can't never see it the rest of my
life i won't be able to see it
so then i started i don't know where it
came from
i surrender all
i surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender
all i sang and i cried i
sang and i cried and i prayed some more
until
i could reach the point where not only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress i can bless her
i can say i bless you
i bless you i bless you with this i
surrender all i
surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender all
and i tell you in my greatest
testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
[Music]
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me
anymore it had no control over me
anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power
that was greater than i could ever know
the instant that happened a woman comes
running
out of the cafeteria
screaming alfred
is your name alfred
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's saying named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
this is a health retreat
[Music]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound you could lose
this part
[Applause]
no problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said
you're hired you're hired i would tell
my 25 year old self do do whatever
you have to do to make sure you don't
ruin your name
you have to be the most dependable
person anybody knows
starting with yourself you have to be
the person you depend on okay so
if smoking weed on the weekends or
drinking or having hangovers or hanging
out with those people
like makes you feel less about yourself
less you have less trust for yourself
you've got to knock those things off
when this is done maybe make a list
no no make a list go maybe make a list
of things that you need to knock off
to destroy your own personal sense of
trust in yourself
this is a big thing that i did when i
was 25. i started doing
whatever i told somebody i would do i
was gonna do if i told you i was gonna
punch you in the mouth i punch you in
the mouth right then
okay if i told you i was gonna be there
at four o'clock i'd be there early if i
told you
i was gonna stay late i would stay late
whatever it was i started building trust
back within myself because the reality
is nobody was gonna trust me
i had destroyed so much trust and
respect
with others and told them over and over
again oh it's gonna be different this
time so
old 25 year old grant rebuild the trust
you have in yourself
and keep doing that until other people
start saying hey you changed
you're different now and that that
started happening literally within about
three to six months
of me starting to make that commitment
to say hey i'm going to start
rebuilding my own personal trust in
myself my personal self-esteem came up i
wasn't using drugs anymore i wasn't
using alcohol anymore i wasn't going out
on the weekends
i was working when my friends were
playing
brings me to the second thing old 25
year old self hey grant
a little little grant dude you don't
know it bro but you're going to be super
successful one day if you do one thing
one thing for the next 10 15 20 years
okay don't get weak on the weekends
week and weekend you know guy told me
once he's like the weekend's
weekend okay weekends were killers for
me
friday night saturday and sunday were
destroyed the rest of my week literally
three days of the week
which represent what i don't know what
is that three into seven seven and a
three that's about
forty percent of my forty percent sixty
percent of my week by production
my entire production capability the 60
was destroyed by
destroyed by that 40 time off friday
night saturday night sunday night
time off is when i noticed that i was
spending all my money and wasting all my
time
listen to what i just said time off
was when all people by the way not just
me
all people spend their money in their
time off and waste their time
time and money time and money successful
people are not successful because
they're special they're successful
because they utilize time and money
so number one okay build yourself
respect number two
whatever that means by the way maybe
drugs don't bother you they bothered me
alcohol bothered me okay it gave me
hangovers i had to recover two and three
hours the next day
so it's not a moral issue it's about
whether you can you can get yourself in
a situation where you can start being
super successful i'm in mykonos greece
man
this weekend this trip by itself will
cost i don't know what do you think
elena
maybe 100 right now every time she goes
into the shop buying she dings me
but i want to be able to take care of
her i don't want to worry about what
she's
been over there what we spent uh at the
uh at the restaurant brings me to the
third thing okay
don't spend money on dumb stuff
25 years old keep this in mind for 35
years
i didn't spend one penny on alcohol not
one penny on
drugs literally what i was saving
about i wasn't i wasn't doing dumb stuff
on the weekends i wasn't wrecking cars
and getting in trouble
i wasn't having to hire lawyers i didn't
waste any money for 25 years on dumb
stuff
you know when you don't drink you don't
gamble people to drink
gamble they take risks they would never
ever take
right they don't show up when they need
it to the next day when they do show up
they show up with a hangover none of
that happened to me for 25 years forget
making money forget adding skills
forget getting talented the fact that i
was no longer destroying myself my
self-worth
my respect i wasn't making mistakes
wasn't getting in car wrecks wasn't
having to hire lawyers
wouldn't wouldn't have him be thrown in
jail none of that was happening for 25
years
if you can just stay out of trouble
be a wild man but stay out of trouble if
you could just do that i guarantee you
that'll be successful okay and keep in
mind i wasn't wasting money
that means i'm not wasting money on
drugs and alcohol and bad decisions and
bad
people and uh the vip bottles and trips
last minute oh let's go to vegas this
weekend we can't afford it but let's do
it
to be life is to be lived you only have
one life that's what my friends were
saying to me they were sucking me down
the vortex
of destruction so
imagine if you spent the next five or
ten years not wasting money on
this is the hard part now this is number
four watches
cars trips and [ __ ]
i wasn't spending money on any of that
stuff
my friends were going on trips to greece
for three days i said dude i
i don't i haven't earned that trip yet
okay i'm not going to greece for three
days because i haven't earned
the right to go to greece for three days
now i just finished i'm on my fourth
week
rome bucharest i'm just telling you the
upside if you pay the price today and
don't do the [ __ ] little grant i'm
not talking to you i'm talking a little
grant
okay if you don't do the dumb [ __ ] right
now
i went to rome bucharest dubai let's
see if i missed one singapore malaysia
thailand the maldives and now
mykonos okay one day i'm going to spend
a month or two on that
yacht right there i guarantee you i'm
gonna spend a month or two on that yeah
it's all gonna be paid out of passive
income
passive income cash flow okay i made a
decision at 25 not to spend
any money out of earned money like if
you can get this
wrapped around your head you know i
think elon musk when he sold paypal he
took the 80 billion the 80
what did he get out of that deal do you
remember you know the story about this
whatever the number was he took 60 uh 80
of that money and threw it in tesla
twenty percent of it threw it in uh in
the solar company
and ten percent threw it in the other
venture the
the the the the boring stuff yeah the
spacex okay
some some variation of that and had to
borrow money to rent
see this is what the super successful do
they go all
in okay so 25 years old i made a
decision until i have
extra money so much extra money that i
don't have to worry about living
i don't have to worry about food i don't
have to worry about bills i don't have
to worry about emergencies
i'm not going to invest any of that
money and when i do invest it it's going
to go into something that will produce
more cash flow for me
for 25 years this is what people don't
know about
you guys hear me ranting having fun
throwing my stuff on the internet what
you don't know what you didn't see was
the 25 years of me just stacking cash
waiting to find the right vehicle to
invest that money in
if you've been following my story you
know what that vehicle is for me okay
it's real estate produces extra cash
flow so i don't have to go work i don't
earn money and spend it i earn money and
keep it
and when there's enough of that earned
money left over i take that money and i
don't spend it i invest it into bricks
into hard properties
assets real assets that throw off more
money
not like this place this place is stupid
that i'm staying at
it's 10 grand a night 11 grand a night
to live here okay plus plus plus
so i would never ever in the first 25
years of my
career spend my money on this place i
didn't do that until i had enough
passive income
go ahead ron just blow it out blow it
out ryan sneezing back
okay and this is exactly what ryan's
doing okay ryan's probably sneezing
right now because he's like dude if i
can just do this for 25 years he's 35
at 50 i guarantee you he'll be wealthier
than i am that's what he told me tonight
anyway
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give
me a hashtag billionairemindset in the
comments below
so i can celebrate you the scariest
moment in my life was march
15 2019 on my wife's birthday
in colorado where i fainted
i broke my neck got a concussion a lot
of
uncertainty about what was happening so
the story is i was doing some research i
love
biohacking i love medical research but i
also have a weak stomach and i can't
uh handle a lot of it so basil vagal
something
anyway i fainted i've never fainted in
my life i felt this kind of queasy
feeling
researching and then i passed out and i
woke up
in a pool of blood uh i'm on the floor
my wife is crying above me uh
now she's kind of happy because she
didn't know if was gonna wake up or not
and she didn't know what happened and i
was dazed i was confused
paramedics came and i'm starting to lose
feeling in my arms and
in my hands and they think i'm having a
heart attack
i get rushed to the hospital we
ultimately find out that i
i broke my neck in two spots compressed
my spine had a concussion
and i was in the middle of a tour
you know i was in the middle of doing 90
days 23 cities
everything was going great and and now
this happens
and i had to wear this every day
for 60 days and i could take it off for
10 minutes a day to shower
so you do everything you eat in it you
you sleep in it
everything it's not the most comfortable
thing but this was my life and
i saved it as a as just a reminder of
what happened and what i went through my
wife signed it she says i love you
get well soon hearts nina and what i
took from it
wasn't that life is uh precious
you know my wife thought that i may not
wake up but she was so grateful that i
did
i didn't take from my life is short and
i need to make it count i think through
my
through my habits through my training
through just watching this content
through everything i do
i try to make that i make today a
priority like today matters
i think you could train that into
yourself without having to have a life
shaping
moment that if you are constantly
surrounded by people who are
who are pushing it who are doing it who
are getting theirs who are
overcoming adversities it reminds you
that today matters that you can do it
too what
i learned the most from that traumatic
event was that i do difficult things
and it's been one of the most powerful
lessons that i've ever learned
is that i do difficult things my agent
asks me when am i coming home
my family asked when am i coming home i
still had a month
on my on my tour i said i'm i'm not i'm
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep going as long
as i can
and we i made it through the whole thing
i meant i might not have i might have
had to leave
you know halfway through or even after
the next stop
um i remember the day i got released
uh we had this giant suburban truck and
the day i got released i wasn't able to
drive obviously now nina would have to
drive this giant suburban truck and
she's
kind of a little person so driving a big
truck was not what she signed up for for
this tour
but now she had a month of driving the
truck and i would have to be passengers
because i couldn't even i couldn't move
my neck right
and i remember trying to get into the
truck when i left the hospital
and i got one foot in
and then i couldn't i couldn't lift
myself into the car i couldn't lift
myself into the truck
i just my spine was hurting too much i
had my headache i was super dizzy from
the concussion
and i just couldn't get in and
nina my wife was trying to push me and
she couldn't get me in either
i said okay let me try this again but
then i couldn't get out
either putting weight forward or putting
weight backwards was just too painful
and i just broke down and started crying
i was just so frustrated i didn't know
what to do next i couldn't go forward i
couldn't go
backwards i'm in massive pain everything
hurts i just want to go
home i just don't want this to be
happening
i just started crying
and i don't get overwhelmed by that kind
of stuff easily so
that was that was a rare instance and
nina didn't know what to do
with me at that point and that was
probably the lowest low for me just that
overwhelming feeling of frustration and
then canceling people
disappointing people and that was the
night of my show so obviously couldn't
go and do my my tour stop in colorado
because i was in the hospital
but going for the next 30 days
wearing this thing for another 30 days
after not going home
not making it easy on myself
sitting at the front i would sit at the
front of these rooms for the next 30
days
for four hours leading my session
answering questions
with pillows behind my back ice packs
behind me
and just do my session and was it as
good as my initial sessions
maybe not did i have as much energy or
fire maybe not
but i felt amazing about myself for
doing it
it's when you're proud of your effort
that's why i think it matters and i
think being able to go through something
difficult and come out on the other side
if you can carry with you not that this
thing happened to you and now your life
is over
but instead i got through that i'm a
survivor i'm a champion i do difficult
things
the reason why i kept this one is
because my friend mark draker said to
keep it i was gonna chuck it away
because i'm not a super
sentimental guy but he said keep it it's
a good it's a good memento for what
happened
i look at this i keep it down there you
can't really see but
i keep it down here in my in my cabinet
and i see it when i walk in
and as a reminder of all the the pain
and struggle that i went through
i mean i couldn't even get changed to go
to the bathroom by myself
and i went through that and what it does
is help put
current day problems in perspective i'm
i'm
upset about what that my youtube numbers
may not be as good
today as they were yesterday now look at
this like that's what i went through
and so again more than appreciating the
value of life
and knowing that my life is short i
think i've trained that more myself just
from
the habits and routines and the content
being around successful people who take
their life seriously
i learn a great lesson in adversity and
that i do difficult things
the problem is you're not proud of
yourself you might post about some
accomplishment you've done on facebook
or instagram
but when it's you by yourself all alone
deep down
you're not actually proud of yourself so
why where does that come from
it's because you've taught yourself that
you set goals
and you don't consistently follow
through so now when you set a new goal
for yourself
you don't believe that you're actually
going to follow through and that
continues to cycle
on and on and spirals down into you not
being proud of yourself
we need to change that today so it
starts with this when you set a goal you
have to follow through
the only acceptable reason for not
following through
is you being proud of yourself are you
proud of the reason
why you didn't follow through so a
couple examples when i started my tour
the very first stop the pre-tour stop
was boston
i had a goal that time that i was going
to run 30 minutes of cardio every day
we drove the bus and i drove the whole
way didn't sleep a wink
got in at two in the morning i hadn't
done my cardio what do i need to do
i need to do my cardio why because i
told myself i committed to doing
30 minutes of cardio every single day
the cardio was the worst cardio of all
time barely
moving right just kind of half eyes
closed
trying to struggle my way through the 30
minutes health-wise i burnt zero
calories it would have been better for
me to go to sleep
mentally though for the mindset i'm
pumped
it's when it's hard and you do the thing
that you
actually build your self-respect your
self-pride
your self-love your self-confidence when
it's easy
and you win you could post about it on
instagram congratulations but you don't
feel great about yourself because it was
easy
but when it's hard and you try that's
when you start building
self-respect self-accountability
self-pride
that's where it comes from and so in
boston i woke up the next day
and i was tired and i had a sluggish
hard day trying to get through it
which was not great for my body but
mentally i'm pumped like i did the thing
when it was difficult
if i just went to bed i would have had
to ask myself am i proud of the reason
why i'm not doing this other people
would let me off the hook
i'm sure the people i went down with
nina my wife danny my camera guy would
have said it's okay go to sleep but it's
two in the morning you drove
all this way it's like it's a strange
day it's not a typical day
you have every reason in the world not
to do it people will let you off the
hook all the time
because they don't hold themselves to
high standards and then they
infect you with their lower standards i
would not have been proud of myself if i
didn't do my run even though the results
sucked it's the effort
that's where the pride comes from now we
went off and did this crazy tour
23 cities 90 days i committed to doing
all of these cities
then i broke my neck in denver
i broke my neck in denver i had to
cancel my denver event
i committed to going that was my goal to
go i committed the people they paid
money we had the refund we had the
cancer we had to apologize
am i proud of the reason why i didn't go
yeah i'm in the hospital
i can't go then we got the kansas city
as my next stop
the doctors didn't clear me to do a full
three hour event
so i could go for one hour so i still
cancelled the event
i refunded everybody their money and
said guys it's off but i'm still gonna
come
like i'll refund you the money i'm still
gonna come we'll do a q a for about an
hour
and we'll see how long i can go take
pictures i book the hotel anyway i can't
get a refund on that so
might as well come out if you want and
everybody still showed up and instead of
going for an hour i went for an hour and
a half
but i didn't go for the full three hours
i set a goal to go for three hours right
that was my initial intention my initial
goal i didn't do it i only went for an
hour and a half
but after the hour and a half i had a
concussion so i'm starting to slow down
i'm getting a little dizzy
getting a headache and so we have to go
we got to leave i couldn't take as many
pictures as i wanted couldn't sign as
many books as i wanted
but i'm still proud i'm proud of the
effort
that i went and i tried that was my max
effort i had to be pulled off because i
had nothing left in me
to keep going right i probably would
have passed out if i kept staying there
a little bit longer
and so are you proud of your effort
that's all i can't judge if you're a
success or not
people message me and dm me and send me
emails and say hey evan should i be
doing this or that
what do you want to do are you proud of
your effort i can't judge
what does your version of balance look
like
what time do you need to wake up in the
morning do you want to wake up at four
or five at six
at noon i don't care i don't care what
time you say you have to wake up at noon
every day amazing i'm pumped for you
are you proud of your effort i'm not
gonna judge your effort
this is one of the single biggest
reasons why so many people fail
you're fronting on instagram and
facebook with this perfect life
meanwhile you're not proud of yourself
and the effort you're putting in so i'm
going to give you a three-step process
follow this you're going to start
hitting your goals and start feeling
better about yourself step number one is
you set a goal
what's your goal what do you want to
accomplish something daily your goal
should be a habit
so for example i want to meditate for 10
minutes every day great i want to run
for 30 minutes every day amazing i want
to
make a youtube video every day awesome
make that your goal some kind of habit
that you can track on a daily basis
this is the start of building
credibility with yourself look at that
goal then and say am i going to hit that
goal
like is that going to actually happen do
i believe in myself enough that this is
going to
happen or am i going to start and stop
and start and stop and then fall off the
cliff and be motivated today but then in
two weeks i'm gonna forget about it
don't let that be you
look at that goal i'm gonna hit it this
is my goal this is important to me i am
the kind of person that when i set a
goal
i follow through unless i'm proud of the
reason
why i didn't right there's a tiny little
bit of reasons that you might be proud
of
but all the other ones you're just not
proud of you were tired
you forgot you were slow you were lazy
you were scared
you were fearful those are not
acceptable reasons you have to be proud
of the reason why you don't follow
through
so one you set a goal some daily kind of
habit that you're gonna do
on a consistent basis now number two
immediate momentum
do one small thing right now to make
some progress
one tiny small thing i call the two
percent difference
get the two percent difference right now
don't worry about getting to 100 do
something right now if your goal was
30 minutes of running great go do your
run you don't have enough time to do it
great do two minutes of running meditate
for 60 seconds
anything send one email out make a quick
30 second youtube video something
immediate momentum you are not allowed
to set a goal and not create immediate
momentum towards achieving it somehow
the
two percent difference right away
because tomorrow you're gonna wake up a
different person
show yourself you set goals you follow
through and you take immediate action
this is the start
this is the rewiring of your identity
right now we're doing it together
so step one you set your goal step two
immediate action the two percent
difference right away
step number three is you take the proud
test
but whenever you're doubting whenever
you look into that thing and say i don't
want to do it
you ask yourself am i proud of the
reason why
i'm not gonna do it and if you get a no
you have to go off and do that thing if
you get a yes okay great
but if you get a no you're honest with
yourself it's just you nobody's gonna
judge you right or wrong
no i'm not gonna be proud of myself you
have to go do that thing you have to
and if you get up and you don't do it
then you need to reset your goal and
make it easier
you need to reset your goal stop setting
a hundred goals and then not following
through
you have zero credibility with yourself
so just set one goal
and do that one thing every day to start
building up
that reputation for yourself not what
other people think of you
the reputation for yourself if you have
a hundred goals and do none of them
stop setting goals it's not working
eliminate all your goals
just start with one goal a day that's it
one simple goal a day to show yourself
that when you set
goals you follow through you're starting
to rebuild and retrain
your identity and then when you do it
you wake up when you do the thing
amazing celebrate pat yourself on the
back put on a song dance you did your
meditation you did your sales calls you
did your youtube videos
you did it you do that consistently it's
time for another goal
you keep injecting that into your life
you need to build that identity
that when you set a goal you follow
through that's who you are
congratulations i'm pumped for you can't
wait to see where you take things
most people don't concentrate long
enough on achieving their goals
so what happens you don't achieve your
goals if you're focused on something
and you do it every day consistently you
will eventually get results
but if you're constantly jumping from
one thing to another from one idea to
another from one activity to another
then you'll never actually accomplish
what you're capable of the problem isn't
lack of creativity or ideas or genius
it's a lack of concentration
and if that's you i want to fix it in
this video today
so let's take a quick look at my youtube
journey i started on youtube over 10
years ago it's crazy
it's been that long and i wasn't very
good when i started
go back and watch my first videos
they're all still up there i haven't
deleted them you can go back and watch
every single one of them see
how much i sucked i'm an introvert this
is not natural for me it took a lot
of concentration a lot of focused effort
and six thousand plus videos later
here i am why because i just kept going
because i kept focused on my
mission of my objective it took me 350
videos until i wasn't completely
embarrassed by myself
350 videos i had to have my sister come
come to the room with the camera focus
on me press record and then leave
because i couldn't film with her in the
room
and that's my sister how is this guy
going to be a youtuber and be on stage
and give speeches and
be a thought leader and deliver
presentations if you can't even
do a simple video with your sister in a
room concentration
focused effort that's the key it's been
every single day we've been uploading
videos
we've done three plus videos a day for
the past five years
every single day i've been sick videos
went up i broke my neck in two spots had
a concussion
videos going up i lost my voice video is
going up all the time
every single day for the past five plus
years it's been at least three videos
across my main channel now my multiple
channels
concentration i'm not very good at this
the point of all this isn't to brag or
say look at me
it's saying that i suck that if i could
do it so can you
the difference is i think a lot of you
guys are way more talented than i am i
look at alex for example who works for
me at tds
he's just so much more naturally gifted
in front of the camera he's funny he's
charismatic
a lot of stuff that i'm not and i've
been slowly grinding away
getting better in front of the camera so
i think a lot of you guys are actually
better than me
or better than what i was and if if you
just kept going if you just kept working
on it
you would you would improve and you
would have the results you're after
you're just not
patient enough you're not concentrating
enough you're not putting in the work
every single day
this great story comes to mind that it
is great and sad at the same time i was
meeting a friend in
orlando another influencer uh
six years ago or so and we met up
and he said i'm gonna be the next gary v
okay great i love it pumped like let's
go i'm i'm just starting my youtube
career
really starting to take off and he's
wants to be his thing and he's to be the
next influencer
i love it and then he posted something
about a year ago or so
and he said you know five years ago i
met evan
at this place in starbucks in orlando
and i told him i was gonna be the next
gary vee
and he was on his career to build his
youtube channel
and fast forward now and evan's got you
know a million million and a half
subscribers
and i'm still kind of where i was
because i didn't put in the work
and so that's what i don't want for you
right he just he has talent he's a
genius so are you
he just didn't do the five years of work
that i did
and he's someone who's actually i think
way more charismatic than i am and so i
don't want that for you i want you to
concentrate on your effort which will
then lead to results
and i'll give you a three-step process
that you can follow to help you get
there
step number one is flip patients and in
patients people have this really messed
up
view on patients and inpatients i think
people are often
impatient with the results so you want
the results immediately
the human nature you want it immediately
but you're very patient with yourself
if you look at what you're doing every
day like i'll do that tomorrow you get
an idea
yeah i'll start monday i'll start next
week i'll start and i'll start next year
fresh year start out fresh all that
right no you flip it
you flip it you flip patience and
impatience what i want you to do is have
patience with the results
that the results will come and
impatience with yourself
that today matters today you're watching
this i don't know what time it is during
the day you're watching this
today matters what you create today has
to mean something because if you
approached every day with massive
impatience for yourself and your effort
and you did that every day you did the
work that you were proud of yourself for
your effort i promise you that the
results are going to come
but it will take some time to get to
your big goals
you have big goals right you want to you
want to do something big you have big
ambitions you don't want just some tiny
little win
awesome that's going to take some time
even if you're hustling and grinding
and being proud of your effort every
single day it's going to take some time
so patience with the results
and massive impatience with yourself
number two is think big and act small
this is where i think a lot of
entrepreneurs get tripped up you need to
think big
and act small so you have a big vision a
big mission something that you want to
go off and change the world my
big thinking is i want to solve the
world's biggest problem right it's
never going to happen in my lifetime and
yet i wake up every day trying to tackle
it
you want to have a big vision the
problem with it though for some people
is that it means you don't start because
to make that big vision happen you need
money you need investors you need camera
gear you need equipment you need a team
you need all this stuff right just keeps
adding up all the stuff you need and
then you never start
that's the problem the reason why some
dummies are winning off of your idea
instead of you
is because they just started because
they acted small
so you think big and that's the
motivating dream that you're chasing
down every day
and you act small what's the smallest
thing that i can do today
just to start building momentum because
momentum is the thing that is missing in
most businesses
you have great ideas you're genius
you're talented i love what you're
trying to do it's amazing you need
momentum
momentum every single day creating a
little bit more momentum
to make that dream come true think big
act small
and number three is schedule for success
look at your calendar
success is your habits right you want to
make sure that your actions
map to your ambitions the actions that
are in your calendar if you did those
things would help you accomplish your
goals your dreams your ambitions
so if you're talking about building a
youtube career amazing show me in your
calendar where every week you're making
time
to make youtube videos if you want to be
an author awesome i'm pumped
show me in your time show me your
calendar where you've blocked it out
that you're going to spend time writing
on your book
most people don't do it and then you
allow all these little things these
distractions to pull you away from the
thing that you want to be doing
you have to put the big things into your
calendar first and block off the time
and protect that time and look at it
from above and not just
your business your personal stuff too
what's a good relationship look like
what's a good health situation for
yourself look like right habits
put in your calendar and then step above
it and look at the week that you're
about to go off and do
look at your week ahead if you did those
things consistently would it help you
accomplish your goals
and for too many people it's no you're
living in reaction mode to other
people's emergencies and then you never
get to do the thing that you want to do
you got to defend your time you schedule
for success so whatever your big goals
are whatever you need to concentrate on
you need to make sure you're spending an
appropriate amount of time on it so that
you get good at it so you can start
getting results and making the impact
that you know you can make
schedule for success if you want to sign
up for the entire billionaire mindset
series for free and get the companion
bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there